alright guys we are here with Josh Stein
from harbor josh is one of the the first
companies that we invested in over at
Morgan Creek so thank you very much for
for coming on thanks for having me pop
and thanks for investing in us yeah
we'll get to the big news that you guys
announced recently here in a minute but
maybe let's just start with your
personal background I mean kind of how
you got all the way into blockchain
crypto and tokenize securities sure so I
got pulled in from a bunch of folks that
I knew from a prior Starbuzz that
zenefits at that time I was the general
counsel as the chief compliance officer
ah so I had strategy and biz dad for a
while
I got really tight with David sacks and
Risa mana and Bob Rebecca no they were
the co-founders at Harbor and so I'd
been at zenefits for about three years
and was ready to take the next step and
reached out to David sacks and asked him
you know what he thought about next
steps and then that's when he brought up
harbor and said you know I should
actually really kick the tires on it so
I knew the team and his folks I really
admired and respected and when I asked
what Harbor was about he said oh it's
about blockchain and it's about crypto
and at that time all I knew was the hype
I'd read in the press and I had an
immediate and very strong negative
reaction and very strong I'd say just
blurt it out that's a Ponzi scheme
everything's going to zero it's much ado
about nothing in my background is for
I'm a attorney by training like you I
was in the Army before I did that and I
was a federal prosecutor for awhile so
that was the mindset that I was coming
through
on this mindset of being concerned about
money laundering about pseudonymity and
just not really understand that your
application but you know when David SAS
Sachs says you should dig it on
something you dig in on it so I did and
I had the utmost respect for Bob and
Arisa and some of the other functions on
Fitz who start out very early at harbor
and as soon as I start kicking the tires
understand the technology and what they
were trying to do I guess I did a 180
got incredibly excited and started
diving and got it and so what are you
guys doing right now at a high level so
harbour was founded to tokenize
traditional Private Securities you can
think an LP interest in a fund to share
in a private REIT which is our current
deal share in a private company like the
shares that you tokenized it goes back
to the origin story of harbor David was
raising his first VC fund a little bit
over a year ago and he wanted tokenize
it he was really in the blockchain
and wanted to give his LPS some
liquidity and when he started diving in
he realized there was no compliant way
to tokenize those LP interests and that
people that had tokenized it before
we're probably gonna run into compliance
problems because when a regulator asks
you who your LPS are you can't just
shrug your shoulders and say I've got a
list of alphanumeric addresses on a
blockchain so he had an aha moment he
said hey there's a business here and
then he pulled in Bob in Teresa and a
few months later they pulled me in and
we're off to the races and there's been
a lot of building and prepping to come
to this day where yesterday as you know
we publicly announced the launch of our
platform in the launch of our first deal
our first tokenized
private securities on the platform in
before we get into the deal specifically
let's talk a little bit about when we
talk about tokenizing the asset right
what exactly does that mean from a
execution or a engineering side so we'll
talk about engineering or how we do it
but first I think let's talk about what
it is we're actually tokenizing
okay so we're tokenizing shares in a
private read so you're not tokenizing
the actual building people say oh we're
going to tokenize the building I'll say
that it's shorthand is convenient
shorthand to say they you're tokenizing
an interest in the entity that owns
the building to tokenize an actual
building means your tokenizing the title
which is something that the county
recorders office would have to do and
there's our experiments that are the
Cook County Recorder's office was early
and experimenting with it but what your
tokenizing is a member interests in the
LLC that owns it an LP interest in the
partnership that owns a share in the
private reef that owns it got it and how
do you do that we do it with a platform
plus a protocol we're a software
platform to onboard and vet the investor
to manage the legal documents and to
manage the flow of funds into the
initial placement then we're also a
blockchain protocol that controls how
that security token trades throughout
its entire life those two things have to
work together
our fundamental thesis is that you
always have to know in real time the
real world identity of buyer buyer and
seller or else you cannot control for
the compliance things you need to
control for and if you don't mind I'll
do a little bit of an extended overview
yeah person works I'm going to start
with the end which is how this trades or
the secondary liquidity and then loop
back to the beginning and run you
through how it works a tizzy so
essentially every time the security
token goes to tread it pings Harbour
harbors the all-knowing trade compliance
Oracle in the cloud and we check all
these complicated private placement
compliance rules and you can boil them
down into the who what and where rules
around who the buyer and seller are
rules around what the trade can be or
what the cap table has to look like and
then finally rules on where it can trade
and baseline are rules around the
securities laws tax rules that are
necessary to maintain tax treatment and
then of rules that the issuer may impose
in addition to that for corporate
governance or other Prudential reasons
so so every time this token goes to
trade it pings Harbor Harbor checks the
who what where if those all check out
trade goes through no one knows harbour
was ever involved these don't trade on
harbor these trade on exchanges they
trade on their GC desks they trade on
marketplaces or bulletin boards and if
any of those don't check out harbour
throws an error and the trade never
happens the best analogy for a variety
of things were going to talk about is
the transition from email to snail mail
and you can imagine us throwing an error
is like an email message bouncing back
and so we
throw an error and I'll say error would
result in too many investors or error
would result in too few and like if you
look at the investment structure of our
first deal it's a private REIT the
private read has a very complicated rule
set has to maintain a minimum of a
hundred investors for tax purposes
not more than $19.99 per class of equity
or else it has to go public non-us
persons have done less than 50% for tax
purposes top five shareholders have to
end less than 50% for tax purposes there
are holding periods special rules for
affiliates and control persons etc I
mean just an endless list of complicated
requirements and any private security
any private placement has that if you
want to be exempt from having to
register from having to do an s-1 and go
public there are these complicated rules
and it's those complicated rules and the
paper bound system that we're in are why
private securities today are
fundamentally illiquid and so we think
our technology unlock unlocks the
potential for liquidity things will
never be as liquid as the public markets
but they'll be far more liquid than they
are today we think let's go a little bit
deeper on this idea of like compliant
automated compliance or compliance
written into code right the law written
into the code because what you're
talking about is basically taking the
existing laws rules regulations and kind
of criteria and you're simply you taking
the English language and how they're
supposed to be applied in every
situation and you're writing it into
that code that then will execute without
a without human oversight meaning on
each individual trait no one's looking
at the trade except the code has been
designed in such a way that it is going
to govern these trades and there's
audits and kind of periodic checking and
make sure the code still works on that
but really the codes governing right is
doing it in real time and it's allowing
the lawmakers or the regulators to go
from being reactive right allowing if
somebody does a non-compliant trade and
they have to come in and enforce and
spend less time money resources so now
you're turning them into more proactive
right that that rejection of a
non-compliant trade right through those
errors etc is this just happening in the
securities market like just can mine
dump on me in terms of where that's
going and why it's important and how to
laterz look at it sure so you can think
of us as an automated transfer agent
transfer agents today impose these rules
in the world in which you fax and you
email and you're only open during
bankers hours and when you're not in the
Hamptons and everything's very difficult
the you're correct all these securities
rules around private placements are
often honored only in the breach today
in other words it happens that people
seldom non-accredited or they have too
many investors on the cap table or
they're not held for the proper holding
periods and no one really has insight
into it no one's really enforcing it if
the specialist they're not using a
transfer agent and lots of folks don't
and what ends up happening is the only
time so a regulator hears about it is
when there's a big lawsuit or an
enforcement action down the road and
what happens is you're years later
you're subpoenaing a bunch of different
your subpoena 20 50 different people you
got banker boxes of documents and you're
that poor government worker on a weekend
trying to put it all together and I've
been there I was a federal prosecutor in
a formal life instead what we do is we
can't enforce all the rules ex ante from
the beginning but we can enforce a lot
of them and so a lot of these rules get
enforced before the trade ever happens
and it prevents improper trades and if
you do have a problem down the road on
the things we can't enforce the
regulator and that issuer who's bears so
much responsibility for this they have a
perfect record of who owned what one
what is the regulator's current position
on the stuff right meaning that my get
you know I think we're yeah we're
publicly on record I wrote a media post
that said I think the SEC will mandate
the use of I said security tokens but
really just this idea of automated
compliance and kind of law written into
code etc in your conversations today
both in the US and internationally all
regulators you know one aware of this
stuff to open to it and three do you
think they'll eventually kind of embrace
it do you think there can have concerns
like where are they kind of sitting on
this right now yes yes yes and yes sir
yeah I mean look we've had conversations
the number of regulars in US and several
abroad everything from sort of informal
half hour chats to more
depth sit-downs with large numbers of
high-level folks
fundamentally I think what's important
to know is there is no regulatory
ambiguity in what harbors going after
these are things that are traditional
Private Securities there's no question
of is this a protocol token or is this a
crypto current these are securities
these are shares these are limited
partner interests yeah so the rules are
clear and our application the technology
to enforce those rules we've worked with
the best outside counsel and the best
minds and we don't think there's any
ambiguity or need for changes in the
rules and like I said we think what
we're doing is pro regulatory a lot of
rules that don't get honored or forced
today we enforce ex ante and then we've
got these great records for the
regulators ex post if it does turn out
to be a problem down the road and we
have designed our systems we use
institutional grade a lot we get
catchphrase because I think it goes to
the depth and care of what we're doing
and what we're building it felt like we
were peeling the world's largest onion
every step of the way there was another
layer to go to figure it out because of
these rules and then how do they apply
with the new technology and where you're
trying to allow for trading we're on a
practical level it couldn't occur before
so people didn't deal with these
situations how does that work out and
we've we used really good people both
externally we hired up to compliance
personnel each of them has more than 20
years of experience at institutions like
Citigroup and JP Morgan and so we feel
that the use of the blockchain to record
and transfer the ownership of these
security interests works really well got
it what are the risks in let's say all
of this happens right all the log gets
written into code and there's automation
around compliance et cetera what risk do
you foresee or where's like the downside
to doing this
I think we can talk short term and long
term so short term I think people are
rightfully concerned about okay where's
the liquidity going to be technology
does not provide liquidity buyers and
sellers create liquidity the technology
removes the frictions of trading and we
should probably spend some time talking
about what those are and why it does
this but we think it enables liquidity
and that there's a desire for liquidity
that once it's enabled will happen but
this is all new so folks there's a
concern that well when's the liquidy
gonna be there and is it going to be
there and that's a fair concern we feel
good it's going to be there but it's
gonna take a critical mass of investment
opportunities and investors and market
makers and other participants we're
excited about this whole ecosystem
that's gotten built out to enable this
all these different companies and
protocols and important players from
qualified historians like BIC go to
prime trust to important protocol layers
like dy DX or Dharma and 0ax
the and license exchanges game built on
that all of that enables and helps to
create participants helped create this
liquidity down the road but that's what
if I was valuing this as an investor I
would evaluate the fundamentals of the
investment and think of the potential
liquidity is an upside so today you
invest in private securities they exist
on paper there's almost no liquidity in
them so if you would invest in this
investment anyway then any potential
liquidity the value of tokenization is
nothing but potential upside and the
other thing is is the use of
tokenization they used particularly of
modern software platforms to onboard and
vet investors and process the private
placement that today is usually done
with faxes and emails and it's very
painful the ability to do that
efficiently and cost-effectively
means you can syndicate more widely in
other words you lower the check size
people can get into investments they
couldn't get into before so for example
we deal with a lot of real estate asset
owners and let me give you an example
using a building in in my hometown San
Francisco so let's say I'm not talking
to people on the Ferry Building but
let's say I did that buildings worth
roughly 300 million dollars if you as
the asset owner wanna raise capital on
that asset you have three choices today
and they all three can be unpalatable
you can sell the Ferry Building but you
don't want to do that you're a real
estate person you love gorgeous property
like that you can raise debt on the
asset you can lever up but you may be as
levered up as you want to be
particularly at this point in the
economic cycle you can sell a minority
interest but if you sell that
$100,000,000 minority interest there's
not a lot of people that can cut a
hundred million dollar check pension
funds sovereign wealth funds cut a
hundred million dollar check and only
one minority interests it's even smaller
group yeah and so what happens is extend
you just put you just put your finger on
it one is is they squeeze your own
valuation live in a number of bit of
bidders
the other is they negotiate onerous
control provisions which when I'm
talking these asset owners they actually
more than the valuation that's what they
don't like they want to lose control the
asset that way so now using the power of
modern software tools and tokenization
in this infrastructure on crypto you can
take that 100 million put it in a single
asset private read a tokenize reader
what we call a Tier II and syndicate it
more widely I'm just gonna round off the
numbers for easy math one hundred
million dollars two thousand max
investors that's $50,000 you invest or
fifty thousand dollars per token or
share how many investors worldwide would
want to be invested alongside quality
owner operators in quality real estate
at that cheque size where they've got
liquidity on the back end where they can
access that and and borrow against it or
sell it and raise money on it anywhere
they've got access to a computer around
the world because as we know and there's
almost almost there's this podcast now
the wonders of the blockchain are with
the infrastructure that's getting built
out you can trade 24/7 365 around the
globe with nearest in taneous settlement
and no counterparty risk and that's a
real revolution
what is the asset classes right or the
types of asset you think this works for
best today right so I completely agree
with the technology's not gonna bring
the liquidity to liquidities driven by
do buyers and sellers want to transact
in it and that's really driven by the
attractiveness of the asset itself right
but are there types of assets that are
more susceptible to finding benefit with
this or seeding it's every asset that is
attractive I think certain assets
benefit from it morn are going to be
more willing to go early eventually
everything tokenize --is essentially
today we record ownership on Excel
spreadsheets a lot of startups in
Silicon Valley their cap table is an
Excel spreadsheet with a law firm the
theorem is the Jain Excel spreadsheet in
the sky that distributed ledger that has
all these wonderful programmable
properties and eventually everything
will tokenize but short term I think
tokenization brings the most value to
those asset classes that consume a lot
of capital are sensitive to the cost of
capital and are relatively indifferent
to the identity investor because then
that opens up the potential for this
liquidity that brings value so so from
the asset owners point of view they can
tap more capital from more people from
more places more quickly at a lower cost
of capital and for the investor they can
get into investments they couldn't
otherwise because it's indicating more
widely they can get liquidity that's
important to them and I've even talked
to sovereign wealth funds we're looking
for more liquidity in their private
investments and then what becomes really
interesting is a world in which you
start to tokenize a lot of these assets
you can now create investments that just
aren't possible before so if you take
all those parameters real estate is one
of the best first use cases and you just
see so many of the startups going into
this I'd say our sales pipeline is all
inbound interest that's it's 75 percent
real estate 25 percent other asset
classes because real estate consumes a
lot of capital it's very sensitive the
cost of capital most real estate
operators will take capital from anyone
that's legal around the world
why start with a property in South
Carolina it will actually make up so
first just describe the property and
then let's talk about why sure so the
first deal that we're offering it's the
hub at Columbia REIT
it's tokenizing approximately 49% of an
ownership interest in the entity that
owns the hub at Columbia it's luxury
student housing in South Carolina just
about three blocks off the University of
South Carolina campus and luxury by the
way this thing's like debt doubt looks
like MTV Cribs of student housing it
does it's um
I did not live that way in college I got
envied I've got it again be as it's got
like a pool it's got this big gym right
it's got all kinds of crazy it does its
I mean college students are living there
living well well some of them are at
least and so it's owned by convexity
properties that's the real estate arm of
dr w which was founded by don wilson i
think what's really interesting is I'd
love to talk a little about the
background of Don Wilson who people
probably know from the crypto space
because I think this deal and what we're
doing with tokenizing securities really
brings together all the different
strands of his background and it's why
is part of the reason why we were so
eager to partner with him for our first
deal so Don started out trading
currencies and derivatives around
currencies like euro dollar options in
the open pits in Chicago 25 years ago ok
did very well and then in the crash of
2008 shortly thereafter he got into real
estate with convexity properties so he
went from something incredibly liquid
which is the FX markets are enormous to
something that's incredibly illiquid
commercial real estate and did very well
there then as you know in 2014 he
founded Cumberland which started trading
in crypto assets particularly Bitcoin so
that is again a highly liquid assets an
alternative currency and lined up with
his FX background so up until say this
dealer a year ago deep experience in
markets and trading deep experience in
crypto and a deep experience in real
estate now we're combining
those things with us first deal with him
right we are taking commercial real
estate which today is incredibly
illiquid we're putting it into using the
crypto technology the blockchain
technology to make it in a more liquid
format that ultimately will allow for
trading and investments in derivatives
and trading based off those investments
that just aren't possible today got it
and then this building specifically rate
what was so attractive about it from a
but I think you know first I mean you
mentioned to me like student housing for
example is like very recession proof
yeah right like what is some of the
elements of the types of real city you
think will be attractive for tokenize
securities first or do you think it's
just all real estate in general yes let
me not talk about this particular deal I
for that I'd have one of our registered
reps talk about it but I think just real
estate as an asset class generally fair
so most real estate is privately held
not publicly held in the public reads
what's nice about these tokenized
private read structures is allows
investors in a smaller check size and
more liquid format to get into private
commercial real estate the now let me
push you out something right I think a
lot of people for rebuttal would be this
sounds like crowdfunding right there and
there's plenty of quote-unquote
crowdfunding type platforms that have
popped up in and around real estate so
there's ones there own equity there's
ones around debt etc in your eyes is it
the compliance the automation that the
true technology that's managing the
capital stack and the trading that
separates it or their other components
that separate from that fundraising
around crowdfunding etc I think there
are other components that well but
liquidity the most important and the
Quai then ties into the legal structures
their location how you structure the
investments so a lot of the crowdfunding
sites you're investing in their funds so
I am Acme crowdfunding sites so what you
are buying is no Pinterest and acnes
fund and Acme is going out there Acme in
other words it's disintermediated you
between you and the owner/operator
[Music]
the some of the crowdfunding sites match
you up directly the the way the
structures work is too often their
various they're a lot smaller deals
they're they tend to be less
institutional quality not always there's
some cement some really quality deals
but historically at least they've been
smaller and less institutional quality
not having the ability to get alongside
and not having that liquidity and the
lot of them are very time limited deals
are three four year deals what this does
is these tokenize private reed
structures you can syndicate far more
widely you can maximum of two thousand
Bester's per class of equity you could
even do a preferred in the common or a
couple different types of preferred nav
four thousand or six thousand vespers
that means you can have a bigger
investment can do bigger deals
institutional quality deals where people
are looking for twenty fifty a hundred
two hundred million and yet still
syndicate them down to a level that
looks like a crowdfunding check size and
then you've got liquidity on the back
end and what's important is using the
blockchain technology like aetherium is
it ties you into this whole ecosystem so
yeah if you're a crafting site you say
wow i'll just develop my own SAS
software solution i'll just allow people
to trade on my site that's like having
an email solution where you can only
email to people in your organization and
i can remember in college we had an
email system you can only email people
on the college campus no one used it but
then i distinctly remember that moment
where suddenly everything could
interoperate Gmail and Yahoo and outlook
and could talk to email systems around
the world because they were open
protocol internet protocol standards
that interoperate and suddenly you're
all these companies springing up and
developing around it and then
everybody's emailing everybody you no
longer sent snail mail you only send me
mail and so it's similar here if you
think of all the different layers of
what has to happen to create a liquid
market commercial real estate there is a
issuing platform think of as the
technical version of underwriting that's
got to happen
that's where Harvard does there is a
custody layer that's what bit go does
there is investment banking layer
which is not necessary technologically
oriented there is there is the exchange
layer which gonna have multiple layers
and for each layer there's different
stacks you gotta develop there's a tech
stack gotta develop a lot attack there's
a regulatory stack you gotta get
licensed you gotta do reporting and hire
the right people there's a business
stack you gotta hire people and create
an organization processes and then
there's a relationship stack she's got
create relationships with investors or
with issuers or with exchange there's a
whomever and so to develop all those
different layers in each stack in each
one and then to duplicate that in every
jurisdiction around the world is never
gonna happen that's why it doesn't
happen today right it's the Internet one
have worked if it was just one
centralized solution owned by one
company it worked because there are
these interoperable standards and so
that's why for instance our first
issuance Azure ERC 20 standard tokens
because it ties into this whole
ecosystem of important players it ties
into qualified historians like bit go it
ties into protocol layers like 0x and
the exchange is being built on top of it
you can think of places like the ocean
you can think of other exchanges that
accept ERC xx standard tokens like
shares post and open finance you can
think about these important protocol
layers that allow you to create these
investments and products that you that
very efficiently that are tough to do in
a paper world so for example um using
dy/dx you can create a levered long or
short on any ERC xx a standard token
with set you can take any arbitrary
groups of ERC 20 standard tokens and
essentially create a token that wraps
them all up it's an ETF on the fly a
custom ETM add a single share single
token level you can talk about Darmouth
allows you efficiently do debt its etc
etc and what becomes really interesting
is let me paint a picture where we end
up and how powerful that is and then we
can talk about how we get from here to
there so imagine a world in which we
start doing a lot of single asset
tokenize reads and we start to tokenize
law the Class A here around New York
where we are now I can now take a token
from each class a building in downtown
wrap it up with set I now have
downtown class-a etf that's just not
possible to do today you cannot make
that sort of micro bet you can do the
same for Midtown for the Upper East Side
for Brooklyn for Queens using dy/dx I
can go long downtown I can go short
Midtown I can go long Manhattan I can go
short the borough's now this starts to
spread nationwide imagine a world in
which people wanted to try and make
investments or developments or bets
ahead of the announcement by Amazon of
where they were putting in their HQ
suddenly now you could you could decide
you know I'm gonna start doing
development plans in Denver but I wanna
hedge my exposure or instead I'm gonna
start buying up pieces of logistics
buildings in or office buildings in
Queens or what have you if you are a
developer you can hedge your exposure if
you are a tenant you can have a piece of
equity in a building that you're driving
value to because you're a large antenna
there are a lot of different ways in
which people can make very specific and
concrete investment theses in ways they
can't today
the public REITs highly liquid highly
fractionated ownership well-run but huge
baskets of properties a huge baskets of
properties you're just betting on an
entire sector or maybe a huge region
private rates or private funds can be
more targeted they usually are not at
the private REITs are usually not the
single asset level and again just a very
illiquid marketplace they don't
syndicate out as widely as they can and
I think it's worth stepping back and
asking well why liquidity or why
fraction why is that important and it
wasn't this is gonna sound like a sales
tech and it is but I believe it which is
modern capitalism got kicked off and
transformed four hundred years ago when
a bunch of Dutchman and a few Englishmen
started meeting at the corner in
coffeehouses of the corners of broad and
wall and in Amsterdam and near the tames
where they trade these newfangled things
called stocks and these newfangled
things called joint stock companies and
so they combined two magical ingredients
fractional ownership and secondary
trading or liquidity you put those two
things together and amazing things
happen and they weren't done before you
had small partnerships ie not like
widely syndicated internship and if
those weren't liquid sort of
highly fractionated ownership of
liquidity does amazing things today
private capital formation exceeds public
capital formation not just in the US but
around the world and the reason why is
going public is an expensive onerous
long process it has a lot of advantages
ownership is highly fractionated right
these companies of hundreds of millions
or billions of shares liquidity is deep
hundreds of millions of shares trading a
day billions of shares on the new york
stock exchange but that going public
does not work for a 20 million dollar
raise or a 50 million dollar raise or
the kinds of private commercial real
estate deals that we want to tokenize
but now what you can do is you can
retain the advantages of private capital
formation which is it's faster cheaper
and easier but you can bring some of the
liquidity in the public markets to
private capital formation we think it's
gonna do two things
it's gonna increase private capital
formation and it's gonna explode a
secondary market that is almost
non-existent today woody are the types
of assets that this technology will
empower that don't exist today right so
these kind of digitally native assets
that people want to trade create benefit
from etc where those look like so I
think some of the interesting ones I've
seen are you know originally people were
creating protocols or dabs on aetherium
and monetization model was create your
own protocol token which mean what
you're talking about there just started
in Europe but is I create a protocol
adapt whatever it is there's a token
associated with it and the way that both
I make money and you as a investor user
is through the appreciation of the price
of the token that's correct people call
these utility tokens some of them
actually has some utility programming
and most of them just simply had to do
with it was a payment mechanism for that
application
but the monetization model really
depended on it being not just used in
that application but being used as a
store a value more widely becoming an
alternative currency and the problem
with that is in a world in which you
start to get widespread use of
blockchain based applications consumers
and businesses are not going to be high
speed currency traders with 2000
currencies this does not nobody can do
that so
so what happens now is you can have
models where you're on a theorem where
you're just charging 1/8 right you're
providing this service using this world
computer to provide this great to
centralized services decentralized uber
or whatever it is and instead of
charging in your own currency that
requires your consumers to be the next
Don Wilson of currency trading instead
they're just paying in that one
Universal payment mechanism ether but
now you can create securities that get a
portion of those revenues that are
equity in your application that that
drive a lot of the same incentives that
you wanted to when you were using
utility tokens so and these would be
native digital so you could create that
uber decentralized app and you could
create a security token that
programmatically got 10% of the gross
revenues that went through the app ok
now I got it
I can see the activity on the app it's
programmatically automatically giving me
my dividends
it is you know of course you're gonna
use the harbor platform because you want
to be compliant and and the
functionality that we provide the
services we provide and then you can see
what's going on and you can create
people who are incentivized in the
success of that in other words if I love
that uber app I can now buy that
security that gives me a portion of
those revenues and have an ownership
interest in this application that I'm
using it seems to me like the digitally
native asset is there's an example and I
actually forget who I can't remember it
may be a lawson baker i think is the one
and loss if i'm wrong I apologize but
basically said look a lot of people
talking about tokenize securities they
want to take the existing equity in the
you know whatever company etc and they
want to basically put it on a blockchain
or they want to quote-unquote tokenize
it but that would be like taking the
newspaper and saying okay what we're
gonna run it through a copy machine and
there's gonna PDF it and we're gonna put
it on the internet and there'd be value
right you could get more distribution
people could read on the internet all
this stuff but you would lose the value
of you know a be testing the headlines
being able to edit in real time comment
sections right you know user-generated
content
the ability to to distribute right kind
of press one button and it goes to all
these different platforms gotcha the way
that newspapers ended up on the Internet
was the ones that one were the
organizations that understood the full
power of the technology began to use it
right I think was the tone of securities
that I saw in the beginning when we were
really talking about this a bunch and
kind of out there was the PDF version
radios people just saying oh I have an
equity I want to just kind of stamp it
over right and then all of the processes
and services that were that were still
needed to make it compliant were you
know relatively bureaucratic slow and
efficient tetris it wasn't that big of
an improvement it feels like to me the
step you guys just took with this single
asset ari private Reid excetera is one
of if not the first full use of the
technology and understand the power of
it and then that's gonna get
supercharged with these kind of unchain
or digitally native assets that know or
are created from the genesis of the
security it's all Unchained right so
it's not my representation it's not kind
of moved from analog to digital what's
your take on how this evolution happens
right so so we're seeing kind of the
first shots across the bow people are
starting to tokenize stuff and they're
trying different things maybe what I
just said is completely wrong maybe it's
right who knows but how do we get from
99.9 percent of the world not tokenized
securities to more than 50 percent
tokenized securities really what's that
big leap or what how do we get there so
we have hypotheses we've got theories
we've got game plans but no one really
knows just as completely fair yeah just
like in 1995-1996 if you'd said how is
it that everything is going to happen on
the internet SAS wasn't invented yet you
didn't have Amazon Web Services you know
Amazon just started going you know then
maybe there's a Jeff Bezos out there who
already you can see far into the future
knows exactly how this is going to roll
out but I think I think what happens is
you start where that liquidity offers
the most value real estate is a good one
I think there's some great examples to
use with sports teams
there are some other great examples of
traditional companies like medical
device companies where they're very
sensitive they raise a lot of capital
they consume a lot of capital and this
could be useful for them and it starts
there and then expands out this is gonna
look like a normal tech adoption curve
it's a bell-shaped curve if you have a
red crossing the chasms a b-school
favorite I've lived it sound it fits
it's true that book is accurate in terms
that the assets that lead the evolution
or is there other things like like let
me give you two examples
is it an asset owner comes in with well
there's a trophy asset or just an
attractive asset says I want to tokenize
this and that's another common milestone
moment we kind of walk our way towards
the evolution of eventually everything's
tokenized or is the more powerful thing
that a huge investor comes in and says
it or is it actually not binary it's
it's you kind of need both at the same
time it builds the liquid mark it's a
ratchet you're ratcheting up on I mean
this is fundamentally Harbor is we don't
do investments on balance sheets so it's
not we're a technology provider we're
like the Salesforce calm and and so you
need to have both as a classic
marketplace problem eBay needs both
buyers and sellers we need both buyers
and sellers exchanges need both buyers
and sellers so are we are focused we're
lonely relentlessly on what we call the
three cues quality owner-operators with
quality assets or funds that are quality
investment because our thesis is you get
those first few quality investments
that'll bring in quality investors
quality investors will attract more
quality investments which will then
attract more quality investors and on
and on you go and it's not just us it's
other folks in the space because all of
us our biggest competitor is not the
other platforms out there our biggest
competitor is inertia from doing this in
paper for four hundred years
what do you if we come back five years
from now right we did another podcast
and we say you know what tokenize
securities didn't work right we actually
this entire thesis was wrong what would
be the number one reason why you would
guess right now that would be true
what's the biggest threat to this happen
I don't I think the threat is being too
early I don't think it's Jenny I don't
think it doesn't happen this but I mean
you can look I mean you look in the
crash of 99 2000 with the internet
stocks every single one of those
business models is a success today even
pets calm the old sock puppet that got
relentlessly parodied I'm blanking on
the name right now as we speak but there
was a company that recreated the
pets.com model exactly and had a huge
exit a year you know every single one
suit van all of them yeah all of them
did so it's not it is gonna happen when
I paint that vision of when I talk to
people in how hard it is to get liquidy
and Private Securities today what the
blockchain does what happens once you
have that critical mass of opportunities
and investors everybody I talk to not
crypto enthusiasts everybody I've talked
in a traditional financial world they
look at me and they say that is gonna
happen and we love it and the constant
what we constantly hear is we don't want
to be first we want to be early I can't
tell you how many big large financial
institutions want to talk to us after
we've done our third deal after there's
a critical mass of trading or whatever
and that's why it takes people who are
pioneers like you know like with Don
Wilson as a pioneer in crypto his
primary trading and as a pioneer and
security tokens there you always need
those early pioneers that are crossing
the Prairie and going into the unknown
it's funny because I've joked with a
couple of friends before it's like a
Venn diagram right usually those
clinical pioneers are folks who are
entrepreneurial or built their wealth
and you know entrepreneurial endeavors
they also have the validation
sophistication reputation and all the
things that you need to when they say
I'm gonna do this people pay attention
but they have to lack the surroundings
of a bureaucratic organization right so
I I talk a lot about you know take a
fidelity for example like Abigail
Johnson and entire family is like pretty
entrepreneurial they've got this huge
Innovation Lab they don't stuff they
launched you a fidelity digital assets
all everything there's only so much they
can do though within the confines of
fidelity right I think $70 asset manager
all stuff takes time I like Don Wilson
who
I'm not comparing him personally to
fidelity but what I'm saying is you have
an entrepreneurial person who's got a
bunch of experience
who's got capital who's got assets and
it's got enough of a reputation that
when they stick the flag on the ground
people pay attention right and I think
we've gone through this exercise of plus
there's 10 15 20 of those people how do
you go find them right and sometimes
it's you can actually not go looking for
the people you go looking for the right
type of asset maybe in token of
securities or you go looking for the
right type of fun you know whatever it
is and those people just happen to be
the ones who own it but if you can find
those kind of champions within certain
asset classes or niches of the industry
that's what we've like really honed in
on we need more of them right there's
not enough of them there today and I
don't know how to go get them so there's
a number of ways you do it some of it is
retail communication we take lots and
lots of meetings and you have to be
careful about getting too sucked in
because there's a lot of folks that just
want to use you as a as a free
one-on-one graduate seminar on
blockchain the other is by focusing on
quality owner-operators quality assets
getting those first few that are people
like Donelson drw and convexity
properties and some of it is getting the
word out like appearing on quality
podcasts and getting the word out and
then finally I think it's being part of
an ecosystem so you know I've gotten
pressed by investors in harbor and
others like well you guys should do an
exchange there's a lot of value there
and you should do a stable coin there's
a lot of value there it's like well yes
but there's a number of problems with
that one is okay that's a whole nother
lift of a tech stack relationship stack
or regulatory stack and what we're doing
is complex and hard enough the other
thing is is there's a reason why DTCC
State Street Goldman Sachs New York
Stock Exchange and high speed trading
firms are not all one company today and
the reason why is all of them depend on
relationships at each level and those
relationships become competitive when
you put it all under one roof I don't
want to compete with exchanges I want to
partner with them I don't want to
compete with 0x and dy/dx and set I want
to create the security tokens that make
what they do so valuable I don't want to
I don't want to recreate the wheel on
custody I want a partner
people who were best-in-class like Mike
Bell she a bit go and I want to become a
play I don't want to compete at being an
investment banker you know our register
reps and I'm working through our partner
broker GCS they're performing Investment
Banking functional there's first few
deals because we have two to prove out
but long term I don't want to compete
with Goldman Sachs I want to be I want
to be that compliance platform that
services them that services JPMorgan
that services others and I think you
know when you're asking who are gonna be
the innovators a lot there's two kinds
of people that top tech early one is
people are tech enthusiasts that's your
da Moses some of it are people for whom
it gives them a competitive advantage it
solves a critical need that nothing else
will and that gets them over the hump
and so I think that is is who are the
Don well since the Sam's L is the bare
Eastern Lix who aren't yet them right
who is the Don Wilson from 20 years ago
who's the Sam Zell from 30 years ago
people who have good track records
they're quality folks but they're not
yet that level for whom this can
differentiate them when we think about
distribution we're talking to potential
Broker Dealer partners across Asia and
Europe it's not going to be the bulge
bracket banks that jump to do it
initially it's going to be those
boutique banks that to your point are
not bureaucratically bound who are nimbu
who can see this for what it is and can
see a real differentiation right what's
the next goldman sachs what's that
boutique investment bank of 20 or 30
really good guys who want to become the
next goldman sachs those are the people
they're gonna jump on this early but who
have the skills the background and the
connections to really legitimate this
and really push it forward in the right
way absolutely all right before we wrap
up I always do a rapid-fire set of
questions other than Harper what's the
most important company in crypto
Vica why institutional custody you need
you need the institution's I know that
in the crypto commune there's a little
bit of a sort of negative reaction short
the bankers but fun I mean that's been
said by wiser folks than me
but fundamentally for what we're doing
talking about securities the
institutions have the vast majority of
the assets and the money to invest and
so you have to provide the institutions
they need to get involved and that's
even true with crypto you've talked
about for Bitcoin at least an
institution of course if you could wave
a magic wand and change or improve one
regulation what would it be the
limitations on maximum ownership in
private companies there's that but that
12g limitation 1999 I would raise it
significant what would you raise it to
in life I'd start by raising probably a
ten thousand and see how it goes and
then incrementally raise it I don't
think they're necessarily need to be
limitations like that it's particularly
in a digital world
the tokenize role in which you can track
this all really well those limitations
made sense we're in a paper world would
be hard to track who the owners were
we're not in that world anymore okay
thanks for most important book you've
ever read
angle of repose Oh what does that wall
refer to that Wallace Stegner
okay what is that so angle of repose
it's a story about a miner and he's a
miner he's a geologist that goes not
like a crypto miner not a crypto miner
net like a real original like an OG
miner yeah oh gee my geologist works
with mining companies that set Turnus
century and it's the story of his
relationship with his wife and his
family and angle of repose as a mining
term when you pile material like a pile
of dirt or stone or grab when you pile
up eventually the angles of the sides
become stable they will neither increase
nor decrease and it's different for each
type of material and so he was using
angle of repose as an analogy to
overtime she built up a relationship
your relationship becomes stable and
there's that angle of repose and what it
means to have that kind of long-term
relationship with somebody ah I like
that a lot it was a purist presence a
phenomenal book I was kinda normal I'll
have to read that I had never even heard
of it I'll let you finish up by asking
me one question but before I do that I
asked one non crypto question you have
to just accept that aliens exist we
always see them depicted as human-like
aliens right the comparable as a human
do you think that there are alien
animals or alien pets I wish people
could see the reaction the facial
expression when I ask this question
people look at me like I'm absolutely
nuts no I'm thinking I'd say yeah I
would say that yes so if the aliens
exist I would say that mathematically
it's a high likelihood I mean if you
read some of the papers are really
interesting and you extrapolate out
statistically you would have pets you'd
have lifestyle you have you would have
you'd have sets of species or beings who
have more powers than others that would
exploit them for food or companionship
or labor or some sort of value one of
the craziest stories of 2018 that like I
don't even think people talk about let
alone talk about for a very short period
of time do you see this Harvard a
Stroeve astrophysicist I think it is who
came out and said there was a
I'll call a UFO it's not the proper
terminology but something entered into
the solar system and moved in a really
weird way and then accelerated out and
he's like my conspiracy theorist he's
never said like you know aliens are real
or that he's like I think that was a
spaceship yeah I did see that I mean I
didn't say like that's the more likely
than not scenarios yeah it's a
possibility it fits the data we have
right fair and part of us is this long
cylindrical form and it looked like
something out of like Star Trek the
original Star Trek absolutely which is
the good one I'm not a next but yeah it
could have been like I mean like I was
looking at thinking maybe they're
tribbles on it or something I literally
when I read that I like reddit for
Python I wait what happened right and
then I we should go back and look
actually if the professor they got fired
from Harvard for for saying the crazy
stuff or if people actually believed it
but to me that's the one story that I
was really talked about all right what
one question do you have for me so I
mean you are known as being an eloquent
and thoughtful advocate for Bitcoin I'll
take the the question you gave me to
your circumstance if Bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies generally don't succeed
in five years why not
so all cryptos is probably more complex
so let me just stick with Bitcoin I
think first of all it can go to zero
right if there's a lot of people who say
like it can't go to zero I think we need
a separate price from it will still run
somewhere on a computer right so what
you know it's long somebody's running
the Bitcoin software it'll still run but
the price could go to zero or it could
be worthless I think that there's a
couple of different things so one
obviously software bug would be
crippling right I don't know if it's
fatal but but it would be damn near
fatal I think that there would
definitely be issues if people lost
confidence in the idea of
decentralization so there's a bunch of
questions around is it actually
decentralized how decentralized is it
who who controls what etcetera but like
for the majority of people they say it's
decentralized no one person or
organization has control if that became
like irrefutably provable that
person controlled it or like the US
government created it or you know
something like that I think that could
be really a big shock to the system
along those lines the what I call a
Immaculate Conception story of satoshi
nakamoto as a person you know a group
who is it we don't know if that was
somehow debunked or we found out the
facts behind it I think that would hurt
the story and so there's the technical
software bug stuff there's actually like
the story I think is really really
important I more important than most
people will admit and then the third
thing is I actually think if the
government or some other regular buddy
came in and banned it
it would actually drive adoption so I
don't think that's a risk the risk that
I think actually occurs is we saw it
today I think it was today there's two
Bitcoin addresses that was added to the
effect last yeah and that's not gonna be
a shock to Bitcoin et cetera but what
that started me thinking about was this
idea well what if there becomes a very
simple way to take away the pseudonymity
to introduce real identity and then you
basically get introduced all of the
sanctions and kind of all the things we
have a nutritional banking system you
almost are like it takes away the idea
of it being an alternate currency or an
alternative financial system and it just
becomes an exact mirror image and so
maybe you get away with like oh there's
no rehypothecation or maybe there is or
that type of stuff but if there's all of
the governmental oversight I think it
would lose some of its luster and usage
and that's not to say that it's used to
sidestep regulation I am of the belief
that there's a lot of things that aren't
other people's business but doesn't mean
doing bad things right and so there's a
fine line there and you know it's um
Zuko said this to me one time that I
thought was a really interesting thing
he said everyone is talking about the
privacy coins like why do you need to
use a privacy coin you must be doing
something wrong right maderos he cashed
all stuff that was the exact same
argument that a larger percentage of
people used and also the government
against encryption I think in the 80s or
90s yes and the rebuttal was no no no no
no this is actually about security and
safety and all the stuff and there was
this big hearing and you know there's a
speech online that you can go let's do
but it's now industry practice right if
you don't have an encrypted website
that's a weird thing right you know
stuff and so if you look at that from
the privacy coin standpoint does that
mean like every token is going to have
encryption and privacy and all stuff
probably there will be elements of that
but also does that carry over into other
aspects of the use case right like does
that actually mean we get comfortable
with the idea that I'm going to transact
with pseudonymous people or
organizations or wallets I don't even
know who you are I just need to know
that you're you know quote-unquote legal
right you're compliant your legal etc I
actually don't want to know your name so
which is it for currencies maybe that
works for securities you have to know
the name secure securities the whole
different case yeah I'll talk about
bitcoins mister but I'd even sort of
take it back you know so you I take it
back even you're doing soon you're using
synonymy now and taking that back to
encryption I take it back several
hundred years before that if you're not
doing anything wrong why do you need why
do you need to be protected against
unreasonable search and seizure and
forced to testify yep there are reasons
why our lives are not open books and
there are reasons why all of us in our
lives have had people who make their
lives in open book and we find those
people toxic and we stay away from them
yep I mean there are it is a hallmark of
a mature person and civilized society
that we have layers of access to our
private cells I couldn't agree more
I think it's a super fascinating thing
and you know look I'm very bullish on a
lot of this stuff but it back in my head
and it could all go to zero and I think
one one piece of this that has precluded
a lot of people from publicly stating
how bullish they are right sucks a lot
of people in private now Michael there's
bullish on something like why don't you
talk about as publicly they're not
comfortable being wrong and Pub
hmmm right so they're actually very
bullish but if they're wrong they're
hedging but if you if you're not willing
to be wrong in public you're never
willing to be right in public and you're
not really informing a conversation
debate and so their response to I think
would be well the upside of
quote-unquote being right in public
isn't anywhere close to the downside of
being wrong in public it's poetry I so
if a completely fair argument the part
that I've just kind of accepted on a
personal level is the authenticity of
this is what I believe I could be right
it could be wrong here's why I think I'm
right and actually failing and being
open about that and just that authentic
approach to it will overcome being wrong
so people that I mean it is if you do a
spreadsheet you calculate all the
probabilities you reduce it down to a
net present value then yes they probably
are right that there's more downside but
those aren't the people that start
valuable industries and valuable
companies and new technologies and new
ways of doing things those are people
who take risks even when they don't
necessarily pencil out because the
uncertainties are so great at the moment
which you can pencil it out in orbit and
know exactly what your ROI is on it is
the moment at which it's an old
established industry they end up working
for the people who who are willing to be
wrong in public one can only hope all
right man thank you so much for this
awesome off to do it again as you guys
took as more assets thank you pop really
appreciate being on absolutely